même si l'organisation mondiale de la
santé combat l'abus d'alcool depuis plus
de 30 ans rien n'y fait nous dit une
grande étude internationale
aujourd'hui on lève son vin plus souvent
que jamais alors ce que l'étude du
lancet nous apprend aujourd'hui c'est
que l'organisation mondiale de la santé
n'atteindra pas ses cibles de réduction
des méfaits liés à l'alcool d'ici 2030
l' oms vise une réduction disposant de
la consommation or la tendance va dans
le sens contraire
en 1990 on buvait 6 litres d'alcool pur
par personne
à l'échelle de la planète l'équivalent
de 350 bien par année en 2007 on
consomme encore plus et en 2030
ce phénomène va se poursuivre évidemment
deux pays à l'autre les écarts peuvent
être extrêmement prononcée et il faut se
rappeler que 40% disent mais ne boivent
pas une goutte d'alcool
mes raisons principales pour ça c'est
bien sûr la croissance économique fait
que les gens ont les moyens de se
procurer de l'alcool est aussi peut-être
une question de politique publique qui
traîne elle se sert à mettre en place
c'est en asie du sud est que la
consommation d'alcool a le plus augmenté
alors qu'elle a diminué en europe et
restent stables chez nous mais le canada
n'est pas à l'abri des problèmes d'une
part le nombre d'abstinents au canada
semble vouloir régressé et elle fait
encore plus inquiétant d'ici 2030 on
voit se dessiner une hausse
du nombre de femmes et d'hommes qui
rapporte des épisodes de consommation
excessive
partout le nombre de consommateurs
excessifs et d'ailleurs en cause révèle
aussi l'étude
la solution selon les experts
consisterait à encadrer la colle plus
strictement un peu comme on l'a fait
pour la cigarette
probablement que si c'était le cas si on
faisait cela on arrivera aux mêmes
conclusions que celles des experts dans
le domaine du tabac et du cannabis 1 où
on le rappelle on a décidé de
complètement interdire la publicité liée
à ces substances psychoactives ces
chemins qu'empruntent et la russie liant
dizaine d'années aujourd'hui on observe
une diminution de 20% de la consommation
d'alcool ici normand grondin radio
canada montréal